[Música]
la asamblea legislativa de el salvador
mayoritariamente oficialista destituyó a
todos los jueces de la corte suprema y
al fiscal general las destituciones de
los miembros del poder judicial generan
alarma por la concentración de poder que
estaría ejerciendo el presidente nadie
bukele
siguen las protestas en colombia en
contra el proyecto de ley de reforma
tributaria principal foco de descontento
ciudadano y aunque las manifestaciones
han tenido un carácter masivo y
mayoritariamente pacífico se han
registrado incidentes violentos y de
choques con la policía el presidente
anunció que se apoyaran a fuerzas
militares para controlar la situación
en venezuela el presidente nicolás
maduro anunció un aumento en el salario
mínimo la medida eleva el sueldo a 2.5
dólares al mes un valor que no alcanza
ni para un kilo de carne en un país con
una hiperinflación que agobia a los
venezolanos en su día a día
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si raúl blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos en el salvador donde el nuevo
congreso de ese país dominado por los
aliados del presidente en haití buque
led y que tomó posesión ayer sábado
destituyó a los jueces enfrentados con
el gobernante y también al fiscal
general una decisión considerada por la
comunidad internacional como un intento
de concentrar el poder en el mandatario
la mayoría parlamentaria acusa a los
magistrados salientes de haber emitido
sentencias arbitrarias veamos el informe
más romeros sala con 64 votos a favor 19
en contra uno ausente queda aprobado el
decreto que destituye a los magistrados
la asamblea legislativa de el salvador
dejó claro que apoya al presidente en
allí bukele en su primera sesión
plenaria el parlamento ostentó su
mayoría para destituir a todos los
jueces de la sala de lo constitucional y
al fiscal general del país
unos funcionarios que habían
protagonizado encontronazos con bukele
por sus investigaciones sobre el
gobierno y su gestión es evidente que
los miembros de dicho tribunal no están
a la altura de las necesidades de el
salvador que claramente necesitan
funcionarios más conscientes más
apegados a la protección de la vida de
las personas
el presidente buque le justificó que es
una decisión que emana de la ciudadanía
cuyos votos le dieron la mayoría en el
congreso minutos después del anuncio el
alto tribunal declaró como
inconstitucional sus propias
destituciones argumentando que pone en
peligro el equilibrio de poderes en el
país y creando un duelo de legitimidades
entre los magistrados de un lado y el
gobierno y el legislativo del otro
la decisión causó revuelo dentro y fuera
de las fronteras salvadoreñas la
oposición y los gremios empresariales lo
tacharon de golpe de estado igual que el
director de human rightswatch quien
opina que el golpe al estado de derecho
es total además altos funcionarios del
gobierno de eeuu se pronunciaron en
contra de la destitución de los jueces y
le recordaron a bukele que la buena
relación entre ambos países está
supeditada a que respete la separación
de poderes
colombia cumplió su cuarto día de
protestas en contra del proyecto de ley
de reforma tributaria principal foco de
descontento ciudadano y aunque las
manifestaciones han tenido un carácter
masivo y mayoritariamente pacífico se
han registrado incidentes violentos y de
choques con la policía
justamente el presidente e iván duque
anunció anoche que se apoyará en las
fuerzas militares para que salgan a las
calles donde ha habido más focos de
violencia la medida se mantendrá según
el mandatario hasta que cesen los hechos
de grave alteración de orden público
conforme a la política marco de
convivencia y seguridad ciudadana como
comandante supremo de las fuerzas
armadas la figura de asistencia militar
seguirá vigente en los centros urbanos
donde existe un alto riesgo para la
integridad de los ciudadanos y donde se
requiere emplear toda la capacidad del
estado para proteger a la población
la asistencia militar está consagrada en
la constitución y la ley y se mantendrá
en coordinación con alcaldes y
gobernadores hasta que cesen los hechos
de grave alteración del orden público y
es que sólo en cali en el suroccidente
de colombia una de las ciudades más
sacudidas por las protestas la red de
derechos humanos llamada francisco
isaías informó haber recibido la
denuncia de 14 personas asesinadas por
disparos policiales cuando el ministerio
de defensa sólo constató un
fallecimiento en la mañana del primero
de mayo otros abusos ya han sido
reportados por otros grupos más temprano
a nuestro enviado especial tuits muñoz
nos envió el siguiente informe de ese
canal
tras más de siete horas de espera en el
aeropuerto para poder acceder a la
ciudad de cali la cual ha tenido durante
toda la jornada sus accesos cerrados la
imagen que nos hemos encontrado al
entrar es la de una situación de después
de una batalla una imagen que puede dar
titulares pero sin embargo dista de la
realidad ya que la mayoría de marchas en
colombia han sido de carácter pacífico
un pacifismo que precisamente no es el
que las organizaciones sociales recogen
de la actividad de la fuerza policial y
es que el 97 organizaciones sociales han
denunciado a la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos abusos entre los que
estarían muertes y también llegarían a
ver abusos sexuales y es que desde que
empezó el miércoles el paro nacional de
colombia contra la reforma tributaria
del gobierno demandó que cada vez hay
reportadas más muertes y algunas
organizaciones contaría hasta decenas la
respuesta del gobierno a estas protestas
ha sido el anuncio del sábado 1 de mayo
del gobierno de iván duque de
militarizar las ciudades que presenten
más desmanes en colaboración con
gobernaciones y alcaldías sin embargo
esto no ha gustado a jose miguel vivanco
director para las américas de human
rigth watch quien ha avisado del peligro
de poder
a la fuerza pública al ejército en este
caso en las calles
y el gobierno de la vecina venezuela
aumento del salario mínimo en casi un
300% con el incremento del salario que
da en 2.5 dólares al mes en un país con
una hiperinflación extrema del sueldo
mínimo no alcanza ni para un kilo de
carne que puede costar alrededor de 3.75
dólares en una economía dolarizada un
cartón de huevos por ejemplo vale 11
millones de bolívares lo mismo que un
kilo de queso con un bono de
alimentación de 3 millones de bolívares
el ingreso mínimo en moneda local
quedaría en 10 millones
me he propuesto la meta que el año 2021
nosotros vamos a recuperar al más alto
nivel el salario mínimo el salario
social el salario integral todas las
contrataciones colectivas y la vida de
la clase obrera venezolana me lo he
propuesto como meta de vida por mi
sangre por mi espíritu por mi alma lo
voy a lograr yo tenemos que lograr
compañeros
en perú se realizó el primer debate de
los candidatos a la presidencia pedro
castillo el partido de extrema izquierda
y keiko fujimori que representa a la
derecha autoritaria compitieron en el
populismo en su primer encuentro de cara
a la segunda vuelta que será el 6 de
junio el encuentro realizado en un
pequeño pueblo de los andes' estuvo
marcado también por la demagogia y la
xenofobia y reforzó la contraposición de
ideas que tienen ambos candidatos sobre
el futuro de perú especialmente sobre la
continuidad del modelo económico liberal
que se ha mantenido desde el ex
presidente fujimori padre de la actual
candidata
india registró este domingo un nuevo
récord en el número de muertes diarias
por coronavirus con más de tres mil 689
después de que ayer el número de casos
superará por primera vez la barrera de
los 400 mil contagios en solo una
jornada con 215 mil decesos en total
desde el inicio de la pandemia india es
el cuarto país con más muertes sólo por
detrás de estados unidos brasil y
méxico- durante las últimas horas
llegaron nuevas ayudas de suministros
médicos procedentes de francia alemania
x tan eeuu y bélgica mientras la nación
trate de hacer frente al peor momento de
esta crisis sanitaria
en contraste con lo que sucede en casi
todo el mundo miles de ciudadanos chinos
visitan por estos días lugares
turísticos como la emblemática muralla
china a propósito de los cinco días de
licencia de primero de mayo en banda
link una de las secciones de la gran
muralla una enorme multitud recorrió los
caminos de piedra sin pensar en la
distancia social
las autoridades se redujeron el aforo al
75 por ciento al tiempo que extendieron
los horarios en un intento por evitar
aglomeraciones
y la nave space ex se regresa a la
tierra exitosamente la cápsula que
transportaba a cuatro astronautas de la
primera misión a la estación espacial
internacional aterrizó en horas de la
madrugada en las costas de panamá city
en florida eeuu para recuperar esta nave
y a la tripulación tras su misión de
seis meses a bordo de esta estación
estación espacial internacional se
desplegaron barcos en la zona en el
sureste de eeuu la tripulación informó
que se encontraba en buen estado según
informó la nasa
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france 24 continúe con
nosotros buen día para todos y feliz
domingo
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo
desde julio de 2000